I would like to increase my understanding of the rife machine. I am a side sleeper. I'm supporting
breast cancer. I alternate sleeping on my sides. The light is in the middle of the bed. So on my left
side it's on my front and on my right side it's on my back. Is this usage acceptable? Yes, so that usage
would be acceptable because the rife is putting out enough voltage and amperage that it's penetrating
your body. So whether it's right up against your body on your back or right up against your
body on the front. Now of course if you have breast cancer you're not having to penetrate your
lungs and your ribcage and your back muscles. If it's going through your front it's going right to
the breast. But remember you have circulated tumor cells that have settled all over your body
and in your lungs as well and in your spine as well. So you have a, you know, rollover on the side
and have certain percentage of the time that it's hit your back certain percentage of the time
that's hit your front. It's perfectly acceptable. Also I have an AA folder AA your name and an AA 11X
folder. Should I be using both or alternating? No, you're, you're, if I've updated your folder
sets March. I don't remember who has asked this question but if I've updated your folder sets March
it has, it is the folder. So if you're, if, if you're folder that you're using it says AA your name
and then a date, then it is, and we're talking to only people with Tilly Robin here with this
question. Then you do your, your program is fully equipped with 11th harmonic frequencies.
I believe I've done that with everybody. So if not let me know. So if you say no I have not,
you have not updated my program since I bought it to November or something then let me know.
But if it has a date after it, then it has the, it has the 11th harmonic and you don't need to use that
AA 11X folder at all.